neurobiology is the study of the cells
in the nervous system and how they
communicate and interact with each other
and eventually all come together to form
the nervous system as a whole the
nervous system is divided into two main
parts the central nervous system which
is your sort of central processor which
is your brain and your spinal cord so
the two pieces of the nervous system
that are responsible for receiving all
of the information from the rest of your
body as well as sending all of the
information from your brain to the rest
of your body and then the other main
category in the nervous system is the
peripheral nervous system which is all
of the other neurons outside of your
brain and the spinal cord and the
function of the peripheral nervous
system is to carry the signals that are
sent from your brain down your spinal
cord to all of your nerves to carry out
any messages that the brain sends to the
rest of the body
a neuron is the basic unit of the
nervous system there are thousands of
different types of neurons but when we
refer to something as a neuron it's it's
considered a cell that is contained
within the nervous system
they do thousands and thousands of
different things motor neurons help move
your muscles they're what communicates
your conscious thought to move
to your hand you know the muscles that
control your hand
there are neurons in your brain that
secrete different chemicals that make
you feel different ways for example
dopamine neurons in your brain are
produce the chemical dopamine which
controls your mood dopamine basically
makes you happy and so when you do
things that make you happy like for
example I love playing music when you
play music you dopamine is increased in
your brain there are sensory neurons
that bring back information from the
environment there are tons of different
types of specialized Sensory neurons
an analogy for a neuron itself I like to
think of it as an email system one
because neurons
use electricity to send signals within
their the cell itself and so there's
three main parts that a neuron possesses
that can be analogous to an email system
so the first part is the cell body which
is you can think of as sort of the
computer the CPU the the central
processor of the cell it's where the
nucleus is it's where a lot of the
molecules are generated then coming off
of the cell body are a processes called
dendrites and they're these little they
look like tree branches coming off
they're very branched and they're all
sort of all over the place and they're
the ones that perceive the signal so
they're sort of the inbox of of the cell
it's where all the information comes in
it's where the information is gathered
and then there's a third process that
comes off the cell body that is known as
an axon and the axon is sort of the
outbox of the cell the axon is the part
of the cell that sends information or a
signal to another cell
a fun fact that I always love to to talk
about neurobiology is that in in the
brain alone the human brain alone there
are more connections than there are
stars in our galaxy which is pretty
incredible to think about